WE LOVE HER. ALL RIGHT
MIKE D FINS. UK SHOULD THE
OR TRADE DOWN SRI CHANCES ARE
THAT THERE WILL BE TWO
QUARTERBACKS GONE IN THE
FIRST TWO PICKS TREVOR
LAWRENCE AND ZACH WILSON.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE
DOLPHINS SHOULD DO IF THEY
SEEN ENOUGH FROM TUA TO SAY,
LET'S TAKE A SHOT WITH
ANOTHER FRANCHISE QUARTERBACK,
LIKE THE CARDINALS DID A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO, OR
SHOULD THEY GIVE TO ANOTHER
SHOT AND GET SOME OTHER AREA
OF NEEDED REST?
I HAVEN'T SEEN ENOUGH OF 200,
BUT THEY'VE CERTAINLY SEEN
HIM IN PRACTICE AND AND
APPARENTLY THINK THAT HE'S
THE REAL DEAL. AT LEAST
THEY'VE SAID THAT PUBLICLY
MIKE AND I GET NO INDICATION
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO USE THE
THIRD PICK ON A QUARTERBACK
IF I HAD ANY QUESTION AT ALL
AT THAT TO IS THE REAL DEAL.
I'M DRAFTING A QUARTERBACK
WITH THE THIRD PICK IF I
DON'T HAVE A QUESTION IF I
THINK TO AS MY QUARTERBACK,
I'M GONNA TRADE DOWN AND GET
THOSE ADDITIONAL PICKS
BECAUSE BOY MIKE THEY CAN
REALLY GET A HAUL OUT OF THIS
DRAFT THAT WILL
AT THEM UP TO CONTEND FOR THE
NEXT FEW YEARS IF INDEED TO
IS THE REAL DEAL. YEAH, AND
IT ALL COMES DOWN TO HOW YOU
FEEL ABOUT WHOEVER IS GOING
TO BE LEFT AFTER LAWRENCE AND
WILSON. DO YOU REALLY FEEL
STRONGLY ABOUT THAT GUY?
WHOEVER IT IS AND
DESHAUN WATSON IS A FACTOR IN
ALL OF THIS TOO. I MEAN THERE
HAVE BEEN UGLY INCIDENTS THAT
EVENTUALLY HAVE GONE AWAY AND
THAT DOESN'T MAKE ANY OF IT.
RIGHT? I'M JUST SAYING THIS
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT I MEAN
MICHAEL VICK WENT TO FEDERAL
PRISON FOR TWO YEARS AND HE
WAS BACK IN THE NFL. I THINK
THAT AT SOME POINT THE
DOLPHINS NEED TO MAKE A
FOOTBALL DECISION ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS A MOVE.
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE WILL
BE
PR FALL OUT BUT AND AND
UNDERSTANDING AND COMING TO
A CONCLUSION AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT THEY THINK THAT HE DID
WHAT HE DID AGAIN IF HE DID
WHAT HE DID AND THIS IS WHERE
I STRUGGLE IN THIS LAND MINE
IF HE DID WHAT HE DID HE GETS
EVERYTHING HE DESERVES BUT
EVEN THEN THAT DOESN'T MEAN
HE GOES TO PRISON FOR THE
REST OF HIS LIFE. I'M I DON'T
I MEAN MAYBE SOME OF THESE
ALLEGATIONS WOULD SET HIM UP
FOR A LONG PRISON SENTENCE IF
HE GETS PROSECUTED BUT FOR
CIVIL LAWSUITS, WHATEVER THE
VERDICT IS YOU JUST MOVE ON
AND YEAH, HE'D BE PUNISHED BY
THE
LEAGUE BUT IT'S NOT LIKE
HE'LL NEVER PLAY AGAIN. HE'S
STILL FAIRLY YOUNG. SO THAT'S
YEAH, I CAN SEE THE SEAN
WATSON PLAYING FOR THE
DOLPHINS ONE DAY MIKE. THAT'S
A GREAT POINT BECAUSE YOU
KNOW, THEY HAVE A QUARTERBACK
THEY COULD TRADE AND THEY
OBVIOUSLY HAVE DRAFT CAPITAL
THIS YEAR AND IT'S DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN BEFORE THE DRAFT THIS
YEAR. BUT AT SOME POINT I
COULD SEE THE DOLPHINS BEING
IN PLAY FOR DESHAU